as part of the devil's two dates I've
been asked as the International
Development Secretary of the United
Kingdom why we attach such importance to
education and polina benefits education
brings beyond education and sell all of
the evidence that we've studied from
countries right around the world
indicates for example if you educated
young girls she will marry later she'll
get pregnant later if you were more
likely to be employed in the formal
sector rather than the informal sector
of the economy she will have better
health outcomes because she would be
better aware and better able to take
care of ourselves that's why we believe
that our huge benefits beyond simply
education and that's why we're making
record levels of investment in countries
to support their education systems we
know how to do we know how to train
teachers to build schools to provide
classrooms that's fine when we helped
abolish user fees in countries like
Kenya and Uganda on the fraidy but to
make hundreds of thousands of more
children turned up to school on Monday
morning that's later work it's changing
lives but also I believe it can change
the future of those countries